good evening
you know that astrazeneca's vaccine is
currently in the final stages of
approval
with the european medicines agency if
all requirements are met
the european medicines agency could
recommend market authorization
by the end of this week but
there is a problem in the supply side
last friday the company astrazeneca
surprisingly informed the commission and
the european union member states
that it intends to supply considerably
fewer doses
in the coming weeks then agreed and
announced
this new schedule is not acceptable to
the european union
that is why i wrote a letter to the
company at the weekend
in which i ask important and serious
questions
the european union has pre-financed
the development of the vaccine and its
production
and wants to see the return the european
union wants to know
exactly which doses have been produced
where by astrazeneca so far and if
or to whom they have been delivered
these questions were also discussed
today
in the joint steering board of the
commission and the 27 member states
with astrazeneca the answers of the
company
have not been satisfactory so far
and that's why a second meeting is
scheduled for tonight
the european union wants the ordered and
pre-financed doses to be delivered as
soon as possible
and we want our contract to be fully
fulfilled
in addition the commission has today
proposed
to the 27 member states in the steering
board
that an export transparency mechanism
will be put in place
as soon as possible the european union
has supported the rapid development
and production of several vaccines
against covet 19
with a total of 2.7 billion euro
we want clarity on transactions and
full transparency concerning the export
of vaccines from the eu
in the future all companies producing
vaccines
against kevin 19 in the eu
will have to provide early notification
whenever they want to export vaccines to
third countries
humanitarian deliveries are of course
not affected by this
the european union will take any action
required
to protect its citizens and rights
thank you
[Music]
you